When I'm hiring a junior iOS developer,
or just about any junior developer,
there are basically two
things that I'm looking for.
I'm looking for
a solid foundation and also passion.
With a solid foundation I
mean that I'm not looking for
quantity of knowledge, but quality.
I will never ask questions about a very
specific detail on some framework.
That doesn't give me the information
that I'm looking for.
I want to make sure that any code that
he brings to our existing code base
will work, will be reusable by
the team and won't break anything.
So I will try to center on questions
that show if he has a solid foundation
on the basics of iOS development.
For example I will always
ask the candidate if she
understands the model,
view, and controller.
How they relate to each other and
what are the main responsibilities
of each of these teams.
A common mistake that many
beginners make is not using
the right method to send information
from one object to the other.
I'm talking about things
like the delegate,
notifications, and
target action for example.
So that's something that I always
ask if he has an understanding of
notifications, when you
should use notifications and
when you should use delegate instead.
That's a common mistake.
So this is the sort of quality of
knowledge that I'm looking for.
Another question that
I will try to ask is
try to find out if he's
passionate about what he's doing.
It's vital that this is not just a job.
It must be your hobby, too.
So a few years ago,
there was an accident in New York where
the pilot of the plane managed to do an
unpowered landing on the Hudson river.
And a few days later,
his resume became public and
it was very obvious why this pilot
was a great hire for US Airways.
His job was piloting an airbus and
his hobby was piloting a Cessna, so
he was a total nerd about flying.
This is the kind of
people you need to find.
If the candidate shows that her hobby
is also programming, that's a hire.
So I'll try to find that by
asking if she has any GitHub
profile that's a must,
any side projects that he or
she is working on by himself and
contributions to open source
software that sort of thing.
That shows that he's really
really passionate about coding.
So that's what I'm really looking for
in a junior IOS developer or
just about any junior developer.